the race to vaccinate americans against
covet is accelerating as new strains of
the disease spread around the united
states
32 states have now detected variants of
the virus
first found in the uk brazil and south
africa
putting even more pressure on the
vaccination push and
on hospitals david begno is in los
angeles where officials
are worried about two confirmed cases in
the city
of the more contagious uk strain david
good morning
good morning look they're worried
because la was one of the hardest hit
communities in the entire country even
before we started talking about variants
this morning we're in east l.a in the
community of boyle heights 90
of the people who live here are latino
and since november within the latino
population here in los angeles county
deaths with covet 19 have soared one
thousand percent
one thousand percent this morning we've
got an exclusive look we're going to
take you inside white memorial medical
center
which is just right over my shoulder two
blocks away because the front lines of
the covet crisis
is here in fact you have active duty
military personnel working right
alongside
civilian nurses trying to save lives
can we do a quick huddle wesley willard
manages the icu
here at adventist health white memorial
this is one of la's hardest
hit hospitals the most difficult thing
is knowing that we're caring for a
patient
that may not make it even given all the
best efforts
on his staff of more than 120 his first
lieutenant lana bagwell
the strength of these nurses and these
healthcare professionals have to do this
day in and day out is amazing to me
she is one of the roughly 20 medical
personnel sent by the u.s department of
defense
as a reinforcement to hold the line
against the invisible enemy
covet 19 she has been on the front line
right here
for three weeks how much time would you
normally give someone to orient
if it was a new employee we'd probably
do with experience
probably um four four weeks with
everything
and you got a shift and a half yes sir
because time was of the essence
time was of the essence
adventist health sits right in the
middle of boyle heights
one of the hardest hit neighborhoods in
los angeles willard says socioeconomic
conditions play a role in this
about a third of all the families living
here make less than
25 thousand dollars a year they have
multiple families living in one home
they're not able to socially distance
some of the stories that i've read you
know backgrounds of the patients
they're the sole breadwinners and they
still had to go to work and it's so
unfortunate
this is in many ways ground zero
absolutely willard himself is a west
point graduate
a former army captain he served active
duty for five years including one tour
in iraq given what you've seen in a war
zone how does this compare
i think there's a lot of similarities in
the ability of our nurses to pull
together
have that teamwork mentality just like
my soldiers did
i felt tremendous pressure because i
didn't want to
drop the ball so i felt tremendous
pressure to come in learn everything i
could and really integrate myself and
become part of the team and i think we
accomplished that
active duty military on the front lines
right here in america's neighborhoods
listen here in boyle heights next week
they're going to go into the community
to start vaccinating people a lot of
people who live here may not have
internet access don't know where to go
to sign up
and there are similar issues with
underserved communities around the
country
take new york city for example 24 of the
population is black 30
latino but those groups account for only
eleven and fifteen percent of the
vaccinated
let's go to new jersey it's even lower
fifteen percent of the population is
black twenty percent latino
but they only account for three and five
percent of those vaccinated so gail here
in boyle heights
they're gonna go to people's doors to
their neighborhoods knock on the door
ring the doorbell next week
and offer them the vaccine that way oh
boy david
listen the numbers are so low they're so
tough to hear and it's so important on
this first day of black history month to
get them worried out
this is not a virus that you want to
take any chances with but i know people
are afraid so education must continue
thank you very much david bagnell always
good to see you